hey it's our first movie review of 2018
ya know burnt-offerings yes we're going
back to the we're doing more 7d stuff
cuz I love this [ __ ] yeah I think that
was 1966 I think yeah yeah and so yeah
the last one we did the legacy which was
also kind of a seventies haunted house
kind of movie
this one also a similar type of thing
probably oh well not probably it's
actually one of my favorite haunted
house movies of the 70s and I feel like
it doesn't get like I guess it sort of
has sort of a small cult following but
it doesn't get like the same love is a
lot of the other 70s are modern house
movies I remember seeing trailers for
when it came out and the trailer scared
me if this is a very creepy movie yeah I
think yeah the trailer scared me then
one I ended up seeing it later on
yeah and it's it's a pretty good one
yeah it's a pretty good one I like it
yeah it's um the interesting thing about
it it's kind of a slow burner yeah um
you know which I guess a lot of movies
but um you know I feel like some people
that you know are like kind of like we
need all this stuff to happen you know
we might think it was kind of boring
actually because a lot of it's very
subtle yeah I know I had to have you
with me to go pay attention you see that
when you see that remember when that
happens oh yeah yeah yeah there's a lot
in the very beginning a very so they
don't really explain nothing they just
kind of like leave subtle little hints
that you're supposed to like yeah you
really have to pay attention to what
you're being shown if people aren't you
say anything you just they're just
showing it yeah like what's happening
and in the background and things like
that yeah with the house yeah so it's
one of those kind of things where you
really have to pay attention now one of
the most interesting things I found
about this movie now it's actually based
on a novel by robert moresco and i read
the novel many years ago because it was
in i don't know how many of you guys
remember stephen king's non-fiction book
called Danse Macabre which was kind of
like a series of essays about horror
about what scares you about his favorite
horror novels and things like that and
he had in the back he had this big long
list of what he thought were his
favorite hundred horror novels from like
the 20th century or you know pre 1980 or
whatever and I went through a period
over a few years where I was
to read as many of them as possible so I
did actually get around to reading
burnt-offerings by Robert Marasco and it
was written in 1973 I remember it was
very similar to the movie I think the
end was a little bit different I
remember being really good but here's
the interesting thing
this book and the subsequent film are
very similar similar kind of themed to
The Shining yeah and but the book came
out before Stephen King's book The
Shining came out so and Stephen King
obviously really dug this book so they
inspire the show so he might so this
book might have been one of the things
that inspired the shining now I'm sure
it's not the only thing because he's
also come out and said you know Shirley
Jackson's haunting at Hill House was
also a big influence on the shining too
and you can kind of see that also if you
read that book and see that movie as
well but this kind of theme of house as
living entity yeah I guess we're almost
like a psychic vampire yeah that kind of
aspect pretty much comes from this yeah
or what or was the ghost kind of murder
was the house kind of merged with a
ghost yeah it could have been that to
you which is haunting at Hill House kind
of has that name but yeah and shining
was kind of like that yes that's what I
mean so these are all kind of me not so
much the book yes these are all kind of
like similar kind of things but the girl
I think one of the best things about
burnt-offerings
is the cast yet all-star cast
I love the cast of this movie it is so
awesome yeah um you got Oliver Reed and
your dad and this dude you know Oliver
reads like this big kind of tough
looking British dude and when I was a
kid I always saw him as like one drink
away from whipping your ass was probably
the case he's kind of how kind of
Michael Caine but Michael king he had a
different kind of an intimate and
intimidating factor you know my aunt
Anne was caught a little bit more of a
intense this guy was more like
physically imposing there was something
about him you don't look like a big he
kinda reminds me like a big Bruce
Dickinson
Bruce tickets is not a big dude he's
about my size but he looks a he's like a
big brute
Bruce tickets and that's the way he
always came Oliver Reed and I think I
said this to you when we were watching
the movie a couple days ago I'm like
he's so meaty he's like a big pork roast
oh [ __ ] he's not bad yeah it's kind of
guerilla like I think I only noticed it
because he's shirtless a lot in there
yeah
although wasn't there another movie
where Oliver Reed wrestled the guy like
yeah what movie was that and hiss and
they had sex he asked Karen black I love
Karen black guys I love Karen and she
was sexy all the way out until the into
the 90s the 2002 yeah yeah no she was in
Rob Zombie Rob Zombie movies yes yeah
they look good she was she she held her
own for a long time she yes she's so
cool because she's so weird-looking and
yet somehow and she's all she always
plays like these kind of ladies like
kind of like the mutant barbara eden so
yeah barbara eden goes very cool like
very good knowing about her yeah oh and
if you guys like if you really like
Karen black like I do I uncovered this
really cool like TV movie from the late
70s called I think it's called the
strange possession of mrs. Oliver and
Karen Black is in it and I think it was
written by Richard Matheson actually and
I just kind of stumbled across it one
day on YouTube it used to be and it's
pretty awesome but yeah so Karen black
is in this she plays the mom yeah Betty
Davis
yeah she plays Oliver Reed's
aunt yeah cool layout yeah she's like
cool old lady yeah and she comes along
with them so the whole and she does her
Betty Davis horniness it's kind of cool
her aunt aunt sad I love her character
yeah yes the the acting in this but like
I said it was the 70s like sometimes the
acting is very staged I think we talked
about this a little bit when you
reviewed the hand it's still enjoyable
though but yeah there's something really
charming about that that you can't
really replicate like in business
nowadays then you got burgess Meredith
and burgess Meredith is
yeah he plays a gay guy in a wheelchair
yeah I guess he's supposed to be gay
yeah very Paul Lynde like yeah yeah he
was flaming but he owes he's in it very
briefly but yeah so he's in it too I
remember the kid that was in it
god I want as I've seen that kid before
and you know what I was trying to think
where I've seen that kid I can't rivers
name but I think he was in the [ __ ]
Oh when they did it on Mystery Science
Theater it was like a pile of San
Francisco International okay I'm pretty
sure that this is the same kid that
tried to fly the airplane and they had
to like talk him down and stuff like
that it's very funny if you're into MST
and you haven't seen that episode San
Francisco International it was really
funny oh and also let me mention before
I forget that burnt-offerings was
directed by Dan Curtis who actually
prior to this was mostly known for TV
most famously for dark shadows and he
also directed the very infamous trilogy
of terror which also starred Karen black
in multiple roles but you know the most
memorable one obviously was the one with
the little Zuni doll or whatever it was
called that came after her so I thought
I would mention that there so in some
ways burnt-offerings I've seen it
criticized as being kind of like TV
movie like like the way it's shot and
stuff like that but I don't know I still
think that's kind of a [ __ ]
criticism because I still think this
movie is awesome
but anyway so the whole entire premise
of the movie is that Oliver Reed and
Karen black and the kid and Betty Davis
are you know a family the Rolf family
the x10 family and they are renting a
summer house yeah and looks like a big
ol plantation house yes
so they've answered this ad that these
people put it we're renting the summer
house it's very reasonable the ad says
yeah but I don't think they put the
price in there because they didn't seem
to know what it was when they got there
right later on they telling them yeah so
they get to this house and they can't
believe it like this house is gigantic
yeah and this is an actual I think it's
called Dunsmuir house there's no like
that it's in Oakland California where
they filmed it so it's like it looks
like somewhere outside Savannah Georgia
it really does it was like yeah it looks
like looks like pre-war plantation house
but it is the big columns and everything
I don't think it is a plantation yeah so
they get there and they can't believe
they're like there's no way this can't
be the house that they're running it
looks like a monument yeah and so
they're like well they must be a catch
or it must be the guest house or
something like that so they go in and
they meet this brother and sister
burgess Meredith who was in a wheelchair
and his sister they're the Allardyce's
and they're like yeah we want to rent
this house to quote unquote the right
people yeah and you guys can have it for
$900 for the whole summer yeah yeah and
then the only thing you have to do is
take care of their mom who's upstairs
right
because there's all these feeding
instrum they don't tell them that at
first but I mean Oliver Reed is at first
he's kind of like this is too good to be
true and [ __ ] like that and then he's
like what's the catch what's the catch
and then they kind of get pissy but
they're like oh okay there is a catch
yeah it's like we have a mom mrs.
Allardyce and she's 85 right and she
can't leave the house cuz she's in too
poor health she's just upstairs in her
room she'll never come out you'll never
see her just gonna leave her a tray of
food three times three times a day just
take it right out in her sitting room
and everything will be fine you probably
won't see her it's fine so at this point
Oliver reads like thank you bye and like
they leave but caring black she's like
you be out you insane this place is
awesome yeah I mean because you can tell
as soon as Karen black like walked into
the house yeah
her name is Mary in the movie as soon as
she walked into the house she was like
in love with the place yeah and now it's
not perfect when you see it yeah it's a
little rundown there's some shittiness
to the house the decor is great a lot of
the vegetation is dead the carpeting and
stuff looks pretty rundown I mean yeah
like the wallpaper is kind of peeling
that it's still beautiful but you can
tell it needs work yeah and you can tell
they have been neglected and burgess
Meredith was like I don't worry about
the place you'll see it takes care of
itself
yeah you don't have to do anything
really it's red flesh yeah but it's a
cool flick I think we should talk about
parts if it's gonna go down I think
along the lines of like legacy and the
evil yeah a lot of modern audiences
probably have never heard of this movie
or yeah it is worth watching and
think we should tease the movie but I
don't think we should do too many
spoilers yeah on this one kind of like
what we did on unlike I said I'm like
yeah because we had we can kind of tap
so my regulars went back and watched it
oh yeah that was good
I'm gonna say though like I said for
younger viewers or people who have a DD
or something like that it's not judging
doors I've heard this said people say
this is very slow yeah it seems like
nothing's happening yes no it's not kind
of it's not kind of like a standard
haunted house where there's ghosts and
[ __ ] like that you don't see a lot of
stuff and like I said in that way it's
kind of like haunting a pillow house
where you don't really see anything and
you're not really sure Lee you've gotta
see do you see stuff they just don't
really point it out remember they don't
yeah and the background some of the
things I'm saying they don't like you
don't see ghosts you knows like the
[ __ ] walls aren't blue no nothing
like there's no apparition it's very
low-key there's very low-key no
apparitions in it but a bunch of
paranormal stuff happens yeah
and weird visions and stuff you'll see
cool but you know so it kind of
transpires that you know they they get
left there Karen black starts getting
obsessed with like cleaning the house up
you know she starts doing her duty and
like leaving the food for the lady and
everything like that but obviously
shit's getting weirder and weirder a lot
of conflict starts developing between
you know the married couple and
everything like that and then you kind
of see the house sort of changing yeah
it gets better
yeah so um and their their behavior
starts to get affected and weird stuff
happening you know based on my personal
experience this Hollywood Abnett would
never make a movie like this nowadays
there'd be a bunch of CG in it they
really [ __ ] blow it all right in my
experience this is more like what real
paranormal is as it looks
if it looks and feels more like this
yeah and it does a modern holla'd a
modern Hollywood horror movie well to me
and like I said and I might have
mentioned this on another one but I do
feel like a lot of newer horror movies
at least independent horror movies seem
to be like doing sort of a throwback
thing to late 70s and 80s movies where
they're not really showing a lot where
everything is
like implication or mood and things like
that and I to me that is so much
creepier yeah because and I'm gonna use
here here's an example I'm gonna use I
mentioned earlier the haunting of Hill
House which actually was written by
Shirley Jackson in the 60s or in 1959
rather and is probably my favorite
haunted house novel ever is an amazing
novel and you should read it if you
haven't but they made a movie of it in
1963 and it stuck very close to the book
in that it showed essentially nothing
but was one of the creepiest movies I've
ever seen just everything was subtle and
implied and everything was just the way
things were shot and the lighting and
everything like that and it's really
scary but they don't show anything right
now in 1999 they remade it and it was
just looked like all of CGI had thrown
up all over yeah there was ghosts
everywhere there was a spider bed there
were faces coming out of the wall and
[ __ ] like that it was [ __ ] and I'm
just like why the whole point the whole
scariness of the original movie was that
you weren't sure you didn't know they
didn't show anything right it's like it
could have been a haunting it could have
been her psychological [ __ ] it could
have been all this stuff but in this one
it was just so obvious that that's what
it was and it was just it was stupid it
looks so stupid yeah for me the CGI
doesn't really work with horror not
really uh it's like it can be done but
you just bring that [ __ ] in and rein it
in it's gotta just kind of enhancers yes
but not necess and I think that that's
one of the best things about burnt
offerings is that they don't really show
like you know something supernatural is
going on but it's not super in the
forefront like you kind of have to pay
attention to little things that are
going on it is kind of like The Shining
it is very like the shine I've shed my
shining is a masterpiece of course it's
a lot more intense but this is like if
you like the shining of like this one
yeah it's a similar theme and like I
said I think Stephen King was inspired
by this as
haunting a pill house when he was
writing the shine if he wanted to write
something along that line
I should also know what the creepiest
things about this movie is that
chauffeur yeah holy [ __ ]
I remember him when I was a kid and they
used him in that trailer and that guy
scared the hell out of him when he
rolled that down the window of nono he
rolled the oh the cop and often at that
guy you just what do you see the movie
you'll see it I'm talking yeah and like
you see it now and you go that's not
really a big deal but back in the day
when you were a kid what the [ __ ] you
know what I mean then dude you had a
coffin
whoa and you in the coffin creepiest
thing about him was that you didn't you
don't know who he is or you don't really
like a lot of it isn't explained because
the chauffeur kind of only turns up
because evidently Oliver reads and they
don't really explain a lot of his
backstory a lot of it's just kind of
implication see this movie a couple
times I think really the story oh yeah
like he has evidently had recurring
nightmares about this chauffeur he's
very I mean he doesn't have any makeup
on or anything like that like you know
he doesn't look like a monster dude he's
just a guy but he's super tall and lanky
and he has these dark glasses you can't
see his eyes and he has like this really
really creepy smile yeah it kind of
serves just kind of like a grim reaper
yeah yeah and so Oliver Reed has been
hydrolyzing the guy from phantasm yeah
kind of like oh man you know it's funny
you should mention that because the
house where burnt-offerings is filmed is
the same house that served as the
mortuary in the first fantastic okay so
whoops segue all right and I'm glad you
said that because I would have forgot to
mention it otherwise so this chauffeur
has been appearing in his dream and
we're led to believe that this chauffeur
was at his mother's funeral and he keeps
having like recurring nightmares you see
we don't know if that's what the dude
really looked like or if this is just
you know him like reflecting back on his
past self and that's like freaking him
out the worse manifesting manifesting
itself is that because it is implied
that he had had nightmares about that
guy before
yeah and then they went away and then
when he started living in this house
they came back right and what she felt
end up finding out basically just you
know
give it all away as you suffer as the
people in the house suffer the house
gets stronger right and it starts to
kind of rebuild itself or you think it
does it's really hard to tell because
some things are only seen through carat
a certain characters eyes yeah you know
like you'll see it when you get to that
part you know you're like did that
really happen or is that person just
having a vision you don't know yeah I
want to see the movie again it's a good
one to watch several times because like
I said there's a lot of little bitty
detours time I saw it was a long time
ago I remember liking it liking it but I
don't remember didn't remember much
about the movie and then you showed it
to me again a couple days ago yeah and I
was like yes it's good for ya but I
wasn't able to pick pick up on all of it
yeah and part of the problem was is that
we were watching DVD yeah we don't have
the blu-ray of this yeah transfer is not
audio it's not that good the audio mix
is very muddy a lot of times the
background music and the score is great
really the background music is mixed
very high and the dialogue is mixed very
low so you can't really hear what
they're saying sometimes you're very
muddled you know that a person that one
of the characters said something
important you're like what would they
say yeah you have to like back it up and
yeah but I've evidently the blu-ray is a
lot cleaner yeah and I would like to get
the blu-ray and put it right right
alongside the legacy blu-ray yeah we can
put all our 7 as haunted house heavies
because seventies horror is kind of like
it's an acquired taste but we grew up on
it so yeah you know I've always kind of
curious though if people that didn't
grow up on it get that same because some
people do I mean I have heard like even
younger people that were not even born
then Janet Ilsa saying that that the old
stuff was better that they liked it
better so so maybe isn't just an age
thing like I always thought maybe it was
just because that's what I grew up with
that's what I saw when I was a kid so
that made that's what made the biggest
impact I think from that era the one
that would mess me up the most and we'll
do a show on this one too but I don't
want to get a DVD or blu-ray copy I
don't think there's a what's the tenant
Roman plans that is a depa dad movie
will [ __ ] Roman Polanski's a person
sucks
yeah but his movies are awesome and you
put him in a hole
movie with this character just the
creepiness is just it's just got such a
scumbag and you yeah and I it's on my
list and I really want to do this what
and repulsion is [ __ ] good - I mean
Rosemary's Baby we probably won't do
because I love that movie but you know
everybody knows that one but the tenant
and repulsion I think are a little bit
less seen but I actually I like those
better yeah so um I definitely want to
do the tenant that's for sure give it
ten it's very disorienting yeah yeah
everyone really disturb music in yeah I
even I wrote a big long blog post about
a couple of this I'm afraid I would like
those booth I would think that
Millennials and was listening one
generation what's the degenerate
Generation Y generation Z product sure I
think it would trip out on the tenant
yeah it's a very disorder it's pretty
freaky you're not sure what's real and
what isn't yeah it's weird because very
recently and I know we're kind of going
off tanjit but that's okay very recently
I saw another horror movie I think it
was from 2008 or if she doesn't not I
want to say and I think it was called
occupant and it was obviously based on
the tenant or it was inspired by the
tenant it was it wasn't a remake but it
was like a similar kind of premise and
it was actually very good I was it had
that same like disorienting like kind of
surrealistic and and I love surrealism
at horror when it's done well it's it
disturbs me more than anything else
which is why I love David Lynch movie so
much but yeah I recommend it if you if
you like the tenant if you've seen it
then look out I don't know it used to be
on Hulu I don't think it's on Netflix
though but it's called occupant that's
really good but I was gonna say about
burnt-offerings when you were saying
about the first time you'd seen it I
distinctly remember the first time I saw
this movie I was in junior high school
and my friend Tanya invited a bunch of
us over to her house for a slumber party
now her parents were very very wealthy
hmm and in the town that I grew up in
she lived in a huge huge house like on
the street where all the quote unquote
rich people lived
yeah and these were all you know rich
people these weren't like the new rich
people has these were like old these
were like all the old houses from the
early 1900s and so their house and I you
know my broke-ass is
when I was a kid I grew up in a trailer
park so I'm like a little white-trash
girl and I'm going in this house and I
just like could not believe it I had
only seen houses like this in the movies
right like I walk in and there's like
there's no [ __ ] there was a marble
staircase like one of the big sweeping
marble staircase with the wrought iron
[ __ ] handrails there's a big
chandelier yeah you go upstairs and
there's like all these little like halls
and rooms like servants stairs so just
like a wheel just like them yeah so it
happened that at the slumber party we
had rented a whole bunch of horror
movies like we had pizza and [ __ ] like
that so we go into this like little maze
of the house and we go into this little
back room where there was a little sofa
and there was a little attached bathroom
with a clawfoot tub and all the say that
kind of [ __ ] and we put this movie on
right we were okay we're sitting there
with our little blankies and snacks and
everything we were probably 12 13 years
old and this soon is that [ __ ]
chauffeur shows out yeah everybody notes
the [ __ ] out of the ramp things are
jumped under the covers they ran the
guys were like no no no no no yeah he's
an eerie figure in the movie because I
mean the house we were in looked a lot
like the house it was in the movie and
we just like we were like no we're not
having it so everybody just kind of
scattered and then we there was a large
debate if I remember over whether we
should I actually don't remember if we
watch the rest of it cuz we were all
pretty freaked out all right yeah so
it's a good movie I recommend it it
really is if you are into 70s horror
which would be probably a lot of you
people are and if you're especially into
haunted house movies from that era which
is probably my favorite sub-genre of
horror and you haven't seen it then you
should definitely check it out it's
again a great cast remember you got to
pay close attention to it yeah it's like
you know it's just little things they
don't really spell everything out for
you like you got to look at the
background quite a bit yeah but second
but it's really cool yeah and it's
definitely one that I try to recommend
to people if they've only seen you know
the heavyweight kind of news from that
era it's kind of one that's a little bit
overlooked I feel like yeah it's good
one it's underrated yeah so that'll do
it for our first movie review of 2018
please remember to check
our patreon page or our paypal if you
would like to support the show yeah and
be sure to check out our regular
episodes that come out every Tuesday and
we will see you next time bye